it sparked protests across the country
an unprecedented leak of a draft opinion
showing five of the nine justices on the
u.s supreme court would overturn roe
versus wade a controversial landmark
1973 decision which guaranteed the
constitutional right to an abortion the
leak itself is a little shocking just in
terms of
how the supreme court operates it's
really only happened um a tiny handful
of times in history um the substance of
the leak is of course in some sense even
more shocking because it shows that the
court intends to
overturn about 50 years of precedent on
abortion in the united states
former president donald trump put three
of the justices on the court all three
are conservatives
all three implied during their
confirmation hearings that roe versus
wade was settled law it is a precedent
of the united states supreme court and
one of the important things to keep in
mind about roe v wade
is that it has been
reaffirmed many times over the past
45 years i have an agenda to stick to
the rule of law and decide cases as they
come
the idea the court would scrap the
protection has left some who voted to
confirm the justices
struggling for answers i will just tell
you that it
it rocks my confidence in
the court right now
three and five americans support
abortion rights a new poll suggests even
the idea of scrapping those protections
i said the court's once high approval
rating the court has in the past ruled
in an unpopular way when they banned
prayer in schools for example or where
they extended the right to an attorney
for criminal defendants so it's not that
the court has never been willing to go
against public opinion but in this case
they're taking an issue that seemed sort
of settled for the last 50 years some
justices have expressed the concern at
the damage a leak can do and an
investigation is underway but what may
do more damage is an unpopular decision
and while there are some who will
welcome the direction the court seems to
be moving in its image could take a
beating in the court of u.s public
opinion
alan fisher al jazeera at the supreme
court in washington